LISA WALLS: "We have some of the most complex,
complicated patients, and it has helped up in that
we have this second set of eyes
on our patient.
Intensive care specialists stationed
on the other side of the world
are using their expertise
to aid critical care patients
in Emory hospitals locally,
thanks to a partnership between Emory Healthcare,
Royal Perth Hospital in Australia,
and the health technology company Philips.
LISA WALLS: "If we push the button,
they come on immediately."
TIM BUCHMAN: "And I'm speaking  to you
from the other side of the world, from Perth, Australia."
KATIE CASIE: "So the physician can camera in and see
with very high definition the patient, and the monitor,
and what's going on, and the patient can see the physician back.
And there are nurses also behind the scenes
who watch the monitors. If the patient has a rhythm abnormality,
or a low pressure or a sudden change in vital signs
that alarms, then the nurse can pick it up immediately,
then call us at the nurses' station,
just in case we didn't see it here.
That extra set of eyes will catch it
right on the spot."
TIMOTHY BUCHMAN: "We're kind of life air traffic control
for the ICU.
Keeping an eye on the health
and well-being , identifying
problems as they crop up,
so those problems don't become huge challenges,
and those huge challenges
don't become emergencies
and those emergencies don't become catastrophes.
LISA WALLS: "We can call that at any time
to say 'Hey, this is what's going on with the patient.
'Can you take a look? Just give us a second opinion.
Are we on the right track or do you see something else we could be doing?'
KATIE CASEY: "I work night shift, so there's
just a few people on handle emergencies
as they come up. And having a physician
or somebody else available who is able to offer that expertise immediately,
for me, it helps relieve some of the stress of the job.
It increases satisfaction. The patient gets immediate care.
And I feel like it truly saves lives."
TIMOTHY BUCHMAN: "Our eICU is there to support them,
and make the deployment of our scarce
experienced professionals
more effective and more efficient."
LISA WALLS: "The technology that we have
is cutting edge."
TIMOTHY BUCHMAN: "We can look around the room,
survey all of the treatments and medications
that are being delivered.
We can see the bedside physiologic monitor.
And then using the rest of our screens,
we can look at the entire medical record,
all of the X-rays, CT scans.
We can see everything that the
providers at the bedside can see -- and more."
LISA WALLS: "It's that second set of eyes,
that second set of the critical thinking,
that helps us give really exemplary care here.